- I'm here today to share
some really good tips
on organizing your pantry.
So tip number one is to create zones.
So I created for my family
a breakfast zone, dinner,
snacks, and sweet treats.
It really goes from
most used to least used,
and I love that my kids can
kind of access this level.
Tip number two is to categorize everything
and place it in a bin or a container.
And it's kind of a must for us to label
so that everybody knows
where to put things back.
And tip number three
is really just for you.
When you're making that grocery list,
make sure that you come
over to your actual pantry
and make the list by looking inside.
Trust me, you're gonna save
a ton of time and money
when you go to the grocery store then.
Happy organizing!